blanketed with snow and glazed with ice
homes in texas are burning this part of
the united states
isn't used to freezing the winter storm
has created
chaos electricity grids have failed
leaving millions of people without power
in dangerously cold temperatures we lost
power
yesterday morning and the houses started
getting
real cold like around two o'clock and
then we got all the blankets out we try
to all sleep together to keep us warm
come to the cars to keep our
phones charged and then today when we
got up
there was no water a family of four
died in a house fire near houston while
using their fireplace to keep warm
hospitals have been overwhelmed by
hundreds of people suffering from carbon
monoxide poisoning
and hundreds of thousands have been
advised to boil water
after treatment plants went down and
it's not just
texas that's affected
emergencies have been declared in
several states across the central and
southern u.s
the storm brought thunder snow and
tornadoes
including one in north carolina that
killed several people
president joe biden is promising
additional emergency resources
the extreme weather can be traced to a
mass of arctic air that's normally near
the north pole
occasionally the system is disrupted
sending freezing temperatures south
but it's reported to be happening more
often and scientists are looking into
whether climate change is to blame
events like this highlight the country's
vulnerabilities
businesses in europe in north america in
the middle east
uh aren't going to come away unscathed
and there's going to be significant
costs
in terms of damages unless we start
investing in resilience measures which
you know may seem expensive now but
they'll more likely save money in the
longer run
the governor of texas has called for an
investigation into why services failed
and for the state's power grid to be
improved
in the meantime millions will endure
another night without power
and the cold isn't expected to ease up
until the weekend
alexandra byers al jazeera